este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a las
link no sé vosotros pero entre unas
cosas y otras yo me paso el día entre el
ordenador y la tablet que si trabajo que
si las noticias que si una serie que te
tienen enganchado y al final sin darte
cuenta acabas utilizando cientos de webs
donde tienes que lograr te y estar
utilizar la misma contraseña en todas
las webs pues no es una buena idea si
quieres minimizar tu vulnerabilidad en
la red pues aquí amigos y es donde
intratable y para ayudarnos daschle y
nos va ayudar a generar contraseñas
seguras y cada vez que una web de pie
introducirlas lo hará por ti
automáticamente también te permite
guardar y esto es algo muy cómodo la
info de pago de tus tarjetas para
tenerlo todo siempre a mano rellenar as
todo de forma rápida y sencilla es súper
cómodo y eficiente vamos yo
personalmente esta función la uso un
montón das line también te proporciona
el monitoreo de la edar web que consiste
en escanear la web en busca de datos
personales filtrados o robados alertando
tal instante en caso de que tus datos
personales se encuentren donde no deben
de tal forma que puedas tomar medidas
rápidamente súper útil como dice el
dicho mejor prevenir que curar hazme
caso a tu vida más sencilla y de hadas
ley puntocom barra visual política es
para usar estás lane de forma totalmente
gratuita en tu primer dispositivo y
luego si decides que quieres irte a la
versión premium usa nuestro código
visual político
un 10% de descuento y ahora si
arranquemos con el vídeo de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas no os voy a
contar que la pandemia del coronavirus
ha inflingido durante el 2020 un daño
terrible a muchos países de todo el
mundo no os voy a contar que el virus
extendido por asia europa áfrica y
américa y que muchos gobiernos incluidos
algunos de países tan desarrollados como
españa estados unidos o el reino unido
han dado triste y desoladoramente una
respuesta lamentable tampoco os voy a
tratar de explicar que es el sars
coronavirus 2 no lo voy a hacer porque
todo esto ya lo conocéis de sobra en
este vídeo nos vamos a centrar en la
argentina un país que no solo está
sufriendo el azote del coronavirus sino
que se encuentra envuelto en una
tormenta perfecta' una pandemia una
crisis económica un default y un
enfrentamiento político que acá no se va
a mover nadie porque acá tenemos que no
con una solución ss es definitivamente
es la voz de todo el personal que está
aquí una solución y la solución es ir
con un sueldo básico los 56 por ciento
de aumento y hoy te digo que también soy
sensible al reclamo
de esos policías porque está claro que
han quedado atrasados en sus salarios y
que hay que darles una respuesta pero no
vamos a aceptar que sigan con este modo
de protesta
[Música]
amigos incluso para la argentina el país
que ha hecho de las crisis su seña de
identidad su elemento más característico
casi un atractivo turístico quieres
conocer una crisis una devaluación tal
vez una hiperinflación no lo dude visita
argentina ahora oferta dos por uno pues
amigos desgraciadamente incluso para
este país esta especie de tormenta
perfecta puede ser ya demasiado pero
empecemos por el principio retrocedamos
hasta el mes de marzo del 2020
ah
hemos tomado una decisión en el gobierno
nacional que es dictar un decreto de
necesidad y urgencia por ese decreto a
toda la argentina a todos los argentinos
a todas las argentinas a partir de la
cero hora de mañana deberán someterse al
aislamiento social preventivo y
obligatorio esto quiere decir que a
partir de ese momento nadie puede
moverse de su residencia todos tienen
que quedarse en sus casas
en ese momento las noticias sobre la
expansión del virus por así europa
llevaron al gobierno de alberto
fernández a decretar la cuarentena
estricta el día 20 de marzo el término
oficial que se utilizó fue el
aislamiento social preventivo y
obligatorio
la cuarentena estableció un cierre
prácticamente total del país durante dos
semanas a partir de su entrada en vigor
quedaron suspendidas todas las
actividades salvo las esenciales
relacionadas con los servicios médicos y
la distribución y venta de alimentos el
resto debía quedar cerrado y los
argentinos debían permanecer en casa
también se cerraron los aeropuertos así
como las fronteras terrestres y
marítimas para contener la llegada de
coronavirus argentinas como otros muchos
países entró en modo de hibernación
amigos desde ese momento las cosas
cambiaron prácticamente por completo el
uso de mascarillas se convirtió en la
norma los trenes y los autobuses
viajaban casi vacíos y las calles de la
ciudad parecían un deshabitado pueblo
del oeste y el caso es que está pronta y
enérgica respuesta hizo que la
popularidad del presidente alberto
fernández subiera como la espuma en un
país históricamente dividido a nivel
político sus cifras de aceptación
rozaron el 85 por ciento los argentinos
necesitamos que aparezca un virus que
nos una
sin embargo esperar un momento porque
este no es ni mucho menos el final de
esta historia
hola
poco a poco el entusiasmo y la
normalidad fueron perdiendo fuerza a
medida que la cuarentena se extendió una
y otra y otra vez cada quince días desde
entonces si algunas cosas han cambiado
se ha intercambiado la cuarentena
estricta por medidas severas de
distanciamiento social y contención se
han modificado los términos las
obligaciones pero lo cierto es que casi
seis meses después de ese 20 de marzo la
argentina sigue muy lejos de la
normalidad
ah
y no sólo eso porque como todos sabéis
no hablamos de un país cualquiera una
cuarentena hay unas medidas de
contención tan largas y severas tenía un
efecto terrible sobre la economía de
cualquier país del mundo pero es que
amigos en este caso es aún peor porque
pues porque ya antes de la pandemia la
economía argentina se encontraba en
estado crítico así que os podéis
imaginar lo mal pero mal que pintan las
cosas en este momento ahora bien porque
las cuarentenas y el encierro del país
se han alargado durante tanto tiempo
porque a pesar de ello los resultados
parecen haber sido malos cuál ha sido el
impacto real de esta pandemia sobre la
economía y la política argentina atentos
como un acuerdo con los gobernadores
tomamos la decisión de prorrogar las
medidas de cuidado el aislamiento
sanitario el distanciamiento físico
hasta el próximo 20 de septiembre
y
una estrategia incompleta
[Música]
el día 20 de marzo el gobierno de
alberto fernández declaró una cuarentena
estricta en la que se buscó la
cooperación de la propia población para
hacerla cumplir por ejemplo se creó una
línea telefónica oficial en 134 a la que
cualquier argentino podría llamar para
denunciar a quien estuviese incumpliendo
el encierro migratorio y las medidas
decretadas para enfrentarse a la
pandemia eso te pedimos si sabes de
alguien que no está respetando el
aislamiento obligatorio o de casos de
abusos por parte de la fuerza de
seguridad llama al 134 y denuncia
[Música]
también se puso en marcha una dura
campaña en medios de comunicación para
concienciar a la gente de los peligros
que puede conllevar este virus se
presentó al sars coronavirus 2 como un
asesino silencioso un asesino en masa
fuera de control el enemigo invisible yo
siento que estamos luchando contra un
enemigo invisible que de repente anida
en algunos de nosotros y nos convierte a
nosotros en enfermos y en portadores de
del enemigo
[Música]
el objetivo era concienciar a todos los
argentinos para que se tomaran la lucha
contra el coronavirus tan en serio como
si se tratara de toda la guerra y que de
esta forma pues cumplieran las duras
medidas de confinamiento y
distanciamiento social
[Aplausos]
medidas como por ejemplo tener la
obligación salvo para realizar
actividades esenciales de quedarse en
casa cortar de raíz la movilidad entre
provincias e incluso una vez pasada la
peor parte de la cuarentena la necesidad
de seguir contando con permisos y
autorizaciones especiales para poder
circular por muchos lugares del país
como por ejemplo por el área
metropolitana de la mismísima buenos
aires- y de la aviación y los viajes
internacionales ni hablemos porque
amigos argentinas es uno de los pocos
países donde las conexiones aéreas no se
han retomado de hecho si echamos un
vistazo por ejemplo la aplicación fly de
radar lo que nos vamos a encontrar es
con una situación muy particular poco a
poco los aviones están comenzando a
recobrar el control de los cielos salvo
en la argentina donde prácticamente
desaparece
y es que por poner incluso se pusieron
en marcha medidas tan controvertidas
como la de liberar a muchos presos para
que éstos pudieran pasar la cuarentena
en sus hogares y evitar así que las
cárceles después se convirtieran en
focos de contagio una medida que fue
tomada siguiendo las recomendaciones de
la onu y de la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos pero que ha sido muy
polémica sobre todo porque se han
conocido muchos casos de presos por
delitos graves como asesinatos o
violación que han logrado salir de la
cárcel y bueno tenga una relación porque
seguramente la variable más importante
pues sea el incremento de la pobreza lo
cierto es que durante los últimos meses
todo apunta a que el crimen se ha
disparado en el aumento de la
inseguridad la nueva fase de la eterna
cuarentena coronavirus asesinos y
acusados de abusos lograron salir de la
cárcel por la pandemia el caso amigos es
que tal y como veis no sea aparentemente
el gobierno de alberto fernández fue
desde el principio muy contundente en la
lucha contra esta pandemia nos parece
pues esperar un momento porque sin
embargo hay algo que falla fijaos el
número de muertes por coronavirus se
duplicó en las últimas tres semanas y la
argentina llegará a los 10.000
fallecidos después de 170 días de
cuarentena a pesar de llevar casi seis
meses de cuarentena sin medidas de
confinamiento
y distanciamiento social tal y como
podéis ver en este gráfico la curva de
nuevos casos no da tregua y entonces la
pregunta la pregunta lógica que nos
podemos hacer es qué demonios está
fallando en argentina'
pues amigos atentos a noticias como ésta
coronavirus argentina sólo pudo testear
más que bolivia ecuador guyana y surinam
en la región bolivia guyana surinam es
una especie de broma no se supone acaso
que argentina es un país mucho más rico
y desarrollado pues amigos para que os
hagáis una idea en europa no hay un solo
país que no supere el número de tres por
millón de argentinas ni uno solo ni
siquiera a los que han sido poco
golpeados por la pandemia digamos que
los valores argentinos están más cerca
de áfrica que del 'viejo continente' y
ojo porque una de las estrategias que
comparten los países que mejor resultado
han tenido enfrentándose al coronavirus
ha sido aplicar la tesis de testear
testear y testear es la forma con la que
puedes detectar a las personas que están
contagiadas vigilarlas para impedir que
sigan contagiando a otras personas
y la verdad es que yo no sé cómo esto
funciona en el mundo pero siempre había
escuchado hablar de los tests rápidos y
los tests rápidos son los test
serológicos que se llaman pero no
existía antes rápido para conocer si uno
está infectado o no y la verdad que
estoy feliz que vuelve han hecho
científicos argentinos
pruebas y rastreadores son dos elementos
que se están demostrando indispensables
para superar esta crisis
sin embargo la argentina ha optado por
todo lo contrario el gobierno de alberto
fernández ha apostado prácticamente todo
a las medidas de cuarentena el problema
pues que a medida que pasa el tiempo las
medidas de restricción cuarentenas y
distanciamiento social van perdiendo
efecto digamos que a medida que pasa el
tiempo bien por necesidad económica bien
por agotamiento descrédito al final la
gente va saliendo de sus casas y
regresando a su vida normal de hecho eso
es exactamente lo que pasó a la
argentina muy pronto tras las primeras
semanas de confinamiento estricto el
cumplimiento íntegro de la norma fue
cada vez menos frecuente
ojo no lo decimos nosotros lo dice el
propio presidente fernández 13 de agosto
del 2020 que a mí me sigan hablando de
cuarentena es algo que me asombra porque
la gente sale los números de casos
aumentan porque la circulación aumenta
porque no existen los cuidados que
permanentemente pedimos que existan
alberto fernández presidente de la
república argentina con pocos tests y
con poca capacidad para rastrear y
seguir los casos positivos es muy
complicado por no decir imposible
enfrentarse a esta pandemia eso al menos
dicen los datos
y sé que a los adolescentes que cuesta
mucho estar en sus casas para que tenido
inventiva usar la imaginación de los
adolescentes es un tiempo también tarde
piensas
yo cuento con vos cuídate
ojo es verdad de momento argentina ha
logrado tener gracias a estas medidas
una tasa de letalidad menor que la de
otros países entre otras cosas porque la
evolución de la pandemia aquí ha sido
más lenta y amigos en lakovic 19 la
saturación hospitalaria que se produce
cuando la preparación es muy pero que
muy rápida es una de las causas de que
la vitalidad del virus se multiplique
pero claro de continuar así las cosas
pues veremos luego por otra parte no
podemos olvidar el efecto económico que
tiene una cuarentena hay unas medidas de
confinamiento y distanciamiento social
tan largas amigos argentinas lleva bajo
una economía en hibernación más que
cualquier otro país y claro hablamos de
argentina un país cuyos fundamentales
antes de la propia pandemia no eran
precisamente buenos como todos sabéis
entre otras cosas porque os lo hemos
contado aquí en visual político el país
atravesaba casi dos años de recesión y
se enfrentaba a una deuda impagable y
una inflación desbocada antes de que
fernández decretar la cuarentena y desde
entonces las cosas pues claro no han
hecho más que empeorar
[Música]
argentina está viviendo una caída
económica mayor que la de la crisis del
2001/2002 hasta ahora el peor desastre
económico de su historia según la cámara
argentina de comercio y servicios más de
42 mil pequeñas y medianas empresas han
echado el cierre o están a punto de
hacerlo en mayo el país anunció su
enésimo default y luego según el
ministerio de trabajo casi 2 millones de
argentinos se enfrentan a un panorama
laboral muy complicado en el que sus
empleos están suspendidos que esto
supone aproximadamente 1 de cada 8
empleos del sector privado y dado que el
gobierno tiene que recurrir al banco
central para financiarse no se descarta
que cuando empiecen a normalizarse las
cosas el país puede incluso enfrentarse
a un escenario de hiperinflación todo
esto es lo que explica que la cepal
estime que la pobreza afectará a finales
de año a cerca del 40 por ciento de la
población
amigos la situación de argentina empieza
a ser tan extrema que incluso se ha
detectado ya una ola de depresiones y
crisis de ansiedad al principio de la
cuarentena seis de cada diez argentinos
tenían síntomas leves moderados o
severos de ansiedad con el transcurso de
los días estos síntomas se mantuvieron
pero la angustia se fue transformando en
depresión estamos viviendo una epidemia
de enfermedad mental hoy los argentinos
estamos exhaustos facundo manes y esto
no es todo en el panorama político
social y económico del país del tango
hay otro punto también muy controvertido
la utilización ideológica de la pandemia
veréis me explicó el gobierno de
fernández y muchos sindicatos
especialmente los de los funcionarios
han querido sacar tajada de todo este
asunto ya sabéis y si no bueno pues os
lo digo yo que en la argentina la
política está hasta en la sopa y en este
caso pues no ha sido diferente
el gobierno argentino y sus aliados
hicieron algo que nunca se debe de hacer
en este tipo de crisis buscar una
ventaja electoral a cualquier precio
en este caso una forma rápida de
descargar responsabilidades y buscar una
ventaja para su campaña política veréis
tras decretarse el confinamiento general
el eslogan del gobierno fue el estado te
cuida' lo cual ya dejaba clara cuáles
eran sus intenciones pero no sólo eso
otra idea que se trató de esparcir fue
la de que esta pandemia demostraba que
el mercado era un enemigo a batir e
incluso desde sectores del oficialismo
se describió la cob y 19 con una
enfermedad responsabilidad de los ricos
porque aclaró decían que al viajar al
extranjero lo habían traído consigo en
este tipo de circunstancias extremas y
críticas el estado es el que te cuida no
el mercado un estado presente en materia
de salud es la mejor manera de cuidar a
tus
parece mentira que hablemos de la
argentina un país que una vez fue uno de
los protagonistas de los mercados
mundiales en fin
[Música]
es crisis económica enfrentamiento
político y social una potencia la
hiperinflación en ciernes y la sensación
de que el gobierno no tiene ningún plan
para salir del agujero amigos
desgraciadamente las cosas en argentina
pintan peor que nunca desde aquí no nos
queda otra que desearos muchísima suerte
y mucho ánimo a todos los que nos veis
desde la argentina de parte de todo el
equipo de visual políticos enviamos todo
nuestro apoyo la argentina es un país al
que apreciamos muchísimo ojalá pronto
podamos contar historias diferentes de
este país y ahora ha llegado a este
punto turno para ti que crees que
debería de hacer la argentina para
superar esta crisis déjanos la respuesta
aquí abajo en los comentarios y ya
sabéis si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like suscribiros abisal político una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]